Spain's top court has sentenced nine
Catalan separatist leaders to prison for
their role in the region's failed bid
for independence the Supreme Court
delivered sentences of between nine and
thirteen years in prison
former Catalonian vice president Oreo
whom Karras received the longest at 13
years for the crime of sedition
Catalonia held an illegal referendum in
2017 in a bid to break away from Spain
activists of threatened mass protests in
response to the verdict that's got live
now to the Catalan regional capital
Barcelona al Jazeera Sonia gay ago is
there so Sonia sedition not rebellion
what's the significance of this verdict
well Adrian the significance is that it
doesn't carry the full weight of that
more serious charge of rebellion that
was apparently what one of the public
prosecutors was actually calling for but
there had been leaks in the Spanish
press over the weekend that they would
be more of that charge but it's still a
hefty charge as you mentioned the former
vice-president or elder Garris is
receiving 30 years imprisonment the
others nine years with the politicians
that is so really it's quite a
collective hefty a number of years
imprisonment as well and of course they
also are banned from public office as
well all of them 13 years ban from
carrying any sort of or having any
participation in public office as well
now amongst the politicians have been
charged the former Catalan foreign
minister as well as a speaker of the
Catalan Parliament and the government
spokesperson as well they were deemed to
have been participating or given too
much of encouraging public disobedience
as it were as well but they're also the
other three that were released on
pending those charges as well they have
been charged with disobedience their
parts played in that not deemed to be as
active as the rest they also face a
nominal banned from public office for
about 10 months as well but really this
was perhaps one of
contentious trials that have been facing
this region for years if not decades and
certainly one that is going to guarantee
to cause a lot of public anger amongst
the pro secessionists me reading what
will the impact be on Catalan on the
Catalan independence movement what what
impact will this verdict have well if
the Spanish government was thinking that
any sort of trial or or jail sentence
imprisonment was going to quell any sort
of feelings of secessionism here well
they might be proved wrong with that
because this is definitely going to
guarantee some kind of reaction from
those Catalan nationalists and those
groups that have been calling out for
that those groups who were in favor of
that illegal referendum as well in fact
they're already calling for peaceful
demonstrations to come out already in
the wake of this sentencing as well
there is going to be a statement from
the Catalan president also a special
extraordinary meeting at the Parliament
as well but already you've had a quite a
strong campaign from the independent
issed to call for people to come out
onto the streets and of course the
Spanish authorities have reacted in kind
as well they've already deployed what is
believed to be up to a thousand riot
police officers in case those those
demonstrations turn violent but of
course the Catalan pro-independence
would say that they've called for
nothing but peaceful demonstrations as
they have always done in the past
Sonia many thanks indeed al Jazeera
Santiago a go there live in Barcelona